I'm Phil Phillips from the happy time  murders and we're here to talk about  some of your favorite puppet actors and  movies labyrinth puppets jokes young  Jennifer Connelly and David Bowie with a  ficus on his head what's not to like  Empire Strikes Back I'm not really into  the science fiction but you know Yoda  was the [ __ ] that's a class a badass  right there plus it kind of looked like  an elderly gremlin with food poisoning  so that's pretty cool  Jay Parker and Matt Stone a street of  [ __ ] geniuses man everything they  touch turns into gold which probably  makes it yardmaster me goosebumps nope  nope nope yo Phil Phil Phil nope Night  of the Living dummy more like give me a  [ __ ] out of here child's play man  I wouldn't kick Chuckie out of bed I  would I mean he's a ginger come on girl  like us got up stand yeah kids will high  class gotta impress them and  you  [Music]